pourquoi aimez-vous la but la but mon
c'est sans doute l'endroit le plus
pitoresque de
[Musique]
l'Europe mettez-vous une fois pour tout
dans la tête que le 18e est le seul
arrondissement de Paris à posséder un
funiculaire et vous croyez que ça vous
suffira pour gagner avec tous ces
funiculaires la Suisse n'a quand même
pas plus d'un siège à l'ONU la Suisse à
l'ONU ça commence bien enfin puisque
vous parler de la Suisse sachez que
COMEL le 18e est une montagne monmtre et
que COMEL il voit les gens du monde
entier lui apporter de l'argent en
Suisse cet argent fait des petits à
montmre il fait des souvenirs allez
votre montmre n'est pas le seul quartier
cosmopolite de Paris il n'y a que mont
Parnass pour relever le gant mais mon
martre a des les de noblesse beaucoup
plus anciennes vraiment oui il y a
100000 ans mon martre était allez là je
vous arrête vous allez encore faire
croire que mon Mar est à Marseille très
bien très bien si l'histoire ne vous
intéresse pas peut-être êtes-vous plus
si au chiffre pourquoi pas bon alors
tandis que nous dévisageons les
promeneurs plus ou moins exotiques du
boulevard rochchoire sachez que ce
quartier avait 2200 habitants en 1821
57000 en 1871 et qu'il en compte
aujourd'hui plus de 200000 à quoi
attribez-vous cela au mariage pardis
même quand ils ne sont qu'humoristiques
et
[Musique]
parodiques
mais à montmart on ne fait pas que des
enfants ah non on fait aussi du théâtre
et du bon le théâtre de l'Atelier que
Charles Dulin anima et dirigea jusqu'en
1949 on est le plus sûr témoignage le
18e voyez-vous c'est du théâtre c'est de
la variété c'est du spectacle alors
regardez toutes ces vettes de la Scine
qui viennent vous saluer ce soir elles
habitent toutes dans notre
arrondissement toutes oui toutes et
encore vous n voyez pas Marie Marquet
qui était en voyage au moment du
tournage mais de Sardou à Dalida de
Damien à Cassel divernel à souplex de
Monado à gabrielo en passant par Dano
Barbet bar
nanoli je crois que nous n'avons mis
aucun
grand
théâtre
chanson
[Musique]
musique mais les
cinémas alors là pas de problème ici pas
de film pour SN mais du spectacle du
vrai spectacle de
l'horreur de la chair et du western qui
s'entrelass au gré du
[Musique]
boulevard et puis et puis la sacro
sainte institution du striptias du
striptias quelle horreur comme il est
permanent s'y habitue jolie habitude
ici on s'habitue à
tout
avrivre au jour le jour à la nuit la
nuit comme dit Jacques préver autre
habitant du quartier c'est le règne du
noir et blanc de la lumière et de
l'ombre le monde des contrastes en somme
exactement et comme contraste que
peut-on vous offrir de mieux qu'une
place d'nemé Blanche et un moulin qui
sen ill d'être rouge il a certainement
une histoire oh oui il fut construit en
1885 sur les décombres de l'ancien bal
de la Reine Blanche inauguré en 89 il a
été rendu célèbre par les affiches de
Toulouse l'Autrec que Robert valet ais
de nous montrer merci
silence bon je disais si célèbre
qu'incand dit en 1915 on n'a pas voulu
qu'il disparaisse totalement et qu'on la
réédifie en 1930 mon martre ne serait
pas mon martre sans le Moulin Rouge et
sans sa voisine la rue le pique pour vos
achats de demain voici mesdames notre
dépêche parmi les produits intéressants
vous pourrez
[Musique]
sélectionner vous nous entraînz dans le
monde des qu saisons pour Pierre
macorlan qu'il a longtemps fréquenté la
rue leopique est la seule rue
napolitaine de Paris c'est le pavé où
l'Asphalt qui est livré aux marchandes
et aux acheteuses c'est la poésie
populaire quotidienne goyeuse et tendre
est-ce son seul attait non dans cette
rue habitèrent le poète Gan rictus
Vincent VOG le dessinateur forain et
Jean-Baptiste Clément l'auteur du Temps
des Cerises vous m'en direz
tant et cette rue il faut la remonter
longtemps comme ça ou si vous êtes
fatigué vous pouvez toujours prendre le
funiculaire
et où tout cela nous
mènera-t-il place du Tertre bien
[Musique]
sûr bonjour Gaston comment allez-vous
bonjour j'ai une question à vous poser
pourquoi aimez-vous la but la but mon
c'est sans doute l'endroit le plus
pitoresque de l'Europe
pourquoi parce que là on voit où la vie
moderne a pénétré partout sauf ici ici
on se croirait encore dans un
village bonjour Pierre
bonjour Une questionis vous poser quel
est l'arrondissement de Paris que vous
préférez le
18e et dans le 18e y a-t-il un endroit
que vous aimez particulièrement
oui laab la place du
pourquoi parce que c'est c'est mon
quartier c'est là où je
travaille depuis quand travailleon place
dure depuis le 14e siècle ne vous
déplaise c'est sur cette place que se
dress la pot de justice des dames de
Mont c'est sur cette même place que l'on
St la fin de la guerre de
7071 canon ce fut la tentative de le
enlèvement en 1871 qui déclencha la
commune
[Musique]
tout même pas me dire qu'aujourd'hui on
joue à la pétanque avec les anciens
boulets d'ailleurs en 70 les boulets é
déjà des ob et les joueurs ne sont pas
des canonniers mais des peintres qui se
délassent à proximité du célèbre château
des brouillards qui au milieu du siècle
dernier servit de refuge aux anarchistes
et au faux
monurs
[Musique]